L'histoire a fait la manchette
depuis les d
au Centre Eaton à Montréal,
des agentssésésécurité ont
demandé à une femme d'arrêter
d'allaitouououououououououououùt
de se rendre dans une salle
d'allaitement privée du centre
commercial. On croyait pourtant
que la question de l'allaitement
quelques années, socialement
mais aussi sur le plan légal.
J'en parle avec Louise Langevin,
professeure de droit
Bor r r Madame Langevin.
- Bonjour.
- Il n'y a pas de loi spécifiqus
certains lieux mais ce droit
est tommmmême protégé par
nos lois?
- Oui, dans la situation que
vous soulevez ici, la charte des
droits et libertés du Québec
s'appliquent. Parce que c'est un
cas d'atteinte au droit à
jurisprudence est très claire
sur le sujet. À toutes les fois
qu'il y a un traitement
la grossesse, par rapport aux
capacités pro créatives des
femmes, c'est de la
discrimination fondée sur le
sexe. Parce que ici, Madame qui
allaitait, a été traité
différemment des autres
même espace public. Onààààà
cette femme-là, parce qu'elle
allaitait d'aller ailleurs.
- On lui a pas interdit
d'allaiter, on lui a demandé
d'aller dans une salle à cet
effet là. Es c c c c ces
problématiques quand même?
- Oui, parce que elle, parce
qu'elle allait elle ne peut pas
reauauauauauauauauauauauauauauai
n'allaitaient pas. Donc on luic,
ça porte atteint à son droit àée
femme parce qu'elle allaite.Donn
traitement différent, l'exclu de
l'espace public et reproduit des
stéréotypes et des préjugés à
l'égard des femmes allaitantes.
C'est quelque chose que l'on
cache. On ne parle pas de ça
Donc c'est imposé une certaine
moralité de ce qui est bien et
est ce qui est mal. On r
femme: vous restez dans
privé. La pièce pou
c'est bien cette distinction
entre la sphère publique et la é
exclue de la sphère publique.
- Évidee e e e e e e e qu'il y a
beaucoup d'éducation à faire
encore. Parcé qu'on avait réglé
ça maipapapapapapapapapapapapapr
aux employeurs de donner des
co c c c c c c c c c c c c c c i
travaillent dans des endroits
rerererererereres commerciaux.nt
des gestes intimés privés, seses
dans des lieux publics mais
c'est toute la question de'u'u'.
- Les agents vont-ils interpose?
d'embrassade, je ne suis pas
certain qui vont intervenir.
Mais ici, sur ce qui est intimé
priver, considérés que
l'allaitement est privé et
intime cette image dessin
pourtant il y en a plein.
- Justement, je vous entende là-
dessus. On voit des médias
sociaux qui censuren
expliquer ça, quand on sait tout
ce qui circule s
sociaux et sur le net Sert de
nudité. Difficile de faire
mieux.
- Oui, tout àeeeeeeeeee
cette idée du sein, dès qu'il y
a un simple importe qu'il soitut
en train d'allaiter ou dans des
comporllllllllllllllllllllement
explicites, c'est que le dessin
est à la fois faire allaiter
ma
désir. Spécialement dans une
hétérosexuelle ou c'est l'autre
qui regarde qui décide qui faitu
déplacé. Mais on ne voit donc
bien comment le corps des femmei
allaient dans l'espace public
est contrôlée. Ce que ses
employés là en fait, c'est qu'i
voulait contrôler Madame en
disant que ceci était un geste
faire ça ailleurs. On voit bien
le contrôle du corps des
et le contrôle de la femme dans
ses capacités pro créa
était située cette femme il y
pour montrer des..